When you're traveling by air, you want to be
sitting in a comfortable seat.
Private aircraft take comfort to a level far
above that of commercial airlines with seats
that are as cozy and luxurious as fine
furniture.
They must also be lightweight and fire
resistant.
On private and corporate aircraft.
It's all about luxury seating.
Armchairs often swivel, and at the push of a
button recline with an extending footrest.
The cushions are constructed from layers of
fireproof foam containing carbon fiber for
optimum support and durability.
Workers cut the cushion pieces using a
bandsaw with a round blade that slices
through foam without tearing or shredding
it.
They spray adjoining surfaces with water
based contact cement and assemble them.
The assembly combines different thicknesses
in three different densities to make the
cushions soft in certain areas and rigid in
others.
The densities are color coded after letting
the glue dry for 12 hours.
Workers begin the final shaping.
This is the seat cushion assembly.
They first saw through it laterally to make
it the right thickness.
Then they temporarily adhere a plastic
template of the final cushion shape trace it
then saw along the trace line.
Next, using the technical drawing as a
guide, they mark then grind the cushions
rounded profile, holding the next layer of
foam over the edge.
They verify the shape with another template.
Then they mark lines for the cushions,
creases and with a foam saw, cut them five
centimetres deep, just enough to insert
velcro strips.
The backsides of which they glue to the foam
with water based contact cement.
Workers construct the backrest cushion just
like the seat cushion.
Assembling foam pieces of different
thicknesses and densities.
Shaping the perimeter.
Grinding the edge.
Profile. Cutting and Velcro increases.
Then they apply a final layer of soft foam
13mm thick, folding the edges onto the Velcro
inside the creases.
They do the same with the seat cushion,
armrests and footrest.
All the foam cushions are now ready to be
covered in genuine leather in accordance with
safety regulations.
The supplier rendered the leather fireproof
by treating it with a calcium based solution.
Seamstresses trace patterns for the cover
pieces, then cut them out.
They line the perimeter of each piece with
double faced tape, fold over the edges to
create a neat hem and trim the corners flat.
Then they sew on Velcro strips where
required.
Finally, they assemble the pieces into
covers, sewing an identification label in
each one. They hammer every seam flat to
prevent bulges.
Then they So what's called a French stitch,
a line of straight stitches on either side of
each seam. Meanwhile, workers glue fireproof
polyester batting to the foam.
This layer between foam and leather will
even out the surface.
They tear the perimeter of the batting to
thin it out.
Finally, it's time to dress the cushions in
their covers.
Workers use a metal rod to help push the
leather deep into the creases without
bunching up. Velcro strips on the cover
adhere to the velcro strips inside the
creases. The covers also have velcro
closures and certain cushions have velcro
strips on the bottom which attach to the
seat structure.
Once all the covers are on, workers can
complete the seat assembly.
They attach the armrests to the structure
with screws, then install the footrest which
attaches with velcro.
It contains a cavity for storing the life
vest.
The seat cushion also attaches with velcro.
The passenger seats and pilot seat are
constructed the same way, except that the
pilot seat often has a sheepskin insert on
the sitting surface to absorb sweat and keep
the pilot cool and comfortable.
It was the ancient Romans who first began
using cremation urns.
Today, the custom continues.
The remains are stored in urns permanently
or sometimes temporarily, before burial.
And with cremation, one's final resting
place doesn't have to be six feet under.
The cremation urn has an important place in
some households.
It's a constant reminder of the dearly
departed helping to keep the memories alive.
The urn starts with a concept.
The potter draws a large scale design, which
he'll use as a reference as he shapes a
prototype urn from clay.
He slaps a lump of clay onto the potter's
wheel.
The wheel spins and the potter begins to
transform the shapeless lump into the desired
form. The process is called throwing a
potter's term for shaping.
He leaves the bottom open so the walls can
be more easily formed into the desired shape.
He'll add a base to the urn later as he pulls
up the clay to produce the walls.
He works it to a uniform thickness.
He gathers the top to narrow the opening, a
technique known as collaring.
Then with the potter's wheel at a stop, he
takes the shape from round to rectangular and
tapers it at the neck.
Then it's into a casting box which exposes
only half of the urn prototype.
He brushes a release agent onto that half
using a mixer.
He whips up a mix of plaster and water.
He blends it until it thickens to the
consistency of pancake batter.
The liquefied plaster will harden in
minutes, so he quickly pours it into the box
with the urn prototype and fills it right to
the top.
As the plaster hardens, the exposed urn
prototype makes an impression of half of the
urn. He'll make another one exactly like it
for the other half of the urn.
He'll attach them with a key system for
this.
He drills notches in one mold half.
The notches match up with raised areas on
the other mold half to align them.
He ties the molds together with suspender
like straps, cinching them tightly together.
He adds a base to the urn and straps it to
the other two pieces.
He sets the assembled mold upright, exposing
the opening of the urn.
He's now ready to make a copy of the
original urn.
In fact, he'll make 20 at once using 20
identical plaster molds.
He pumps liquid clay into each one, filling
it to the brim over 3 to 4 hours.
The plaster absorbs water in the clay.
It comes into contact with causing it to
solidify.
The clay in the center remains liquid.
He pours that into a barrel to be strained
and reused.
And now the big reveal.
He opens the mold and removes the urn.
It's exactly like the prototype sculpted by
the potter.
He lifts the lid from another plastic mold
and checks the fit to the urn.
After drying and an initial firing to harden
the clay, a worker coats the urn and the lid
with a glaze.
Working from the inside out.
The glaze is a mixture of finely milled
minerals and water.
It adds color and a glass like non-porous
surface.
When fired a second time.
Cremation urns come in a range of styles and
colors.
Customers often make a selection that
reflects the taste of the deceased.
Another worker now brushes a mixture of wax
and alumina onto the neck of the urn and the
lid. This will keep them from fusing
together during the final firing.
They fire the cremation urns at a very
intense 1195°C for about 15 hours.
This transforms the clay into a durable
ceramic.
They call the urns slowly for 13 hours to
prevent cracking.
Four days in the making.
These urns are now ready to contain a loved
one's remains and in so doing, honor a life.